all right the big ten and the pac-12
have postponed their
college football seasons they intend to
play in the spring you've got some
high-end prospects led by ohio state
quarterback justin fields chris uh
this throws a little bit of a wrench it
really into the planning for the college
football player and look i feel bad for
the player who has spent the last three
months or however long it is you know
one thing we don't talk much about
the college football conditioning
process right brutal
we hear about all the restrictions on
how long you can have the players there
during the season they beat the hell out
of those guys i've heard stories about
what they do at west virginia and it's
hardly an exception they bring those
guys in and they put them through
basically army basic training for months
before they even before they even get
onto the field right and uh these guys
are ready to go and now they pull the
plug and uh they gotta figure out
whether and to what extent they're gonna
hang around for the spring it's crazy i
mean you are right it's it's intense you
know college football yeah they beat you
into the ground and and you know of
course they do that partly because they
they want you to be worn out so you
might not go out you know outside the
football facility and have a crazy night
or act a fool either but yeah these guys
have
absolutely put in some
big time hard work and yes we know that
this is a year where guys like justin
fields you know other guys that we might
not know about you know have done things
and feel like they're about to make a
big jump here under the national scene
and that's not going to happen
you know especially with the pac-12 and
the big ten and you know the big
question there is what do you do
if it becomes no football and you're
playing spring season if you're a guy
like justin fields what do you do
because
again you know the easy thing to say
right off the bat is man don't play
spring football just get ready and get
ready for the draft they're already
viewing you as like a really high draft
pick yeah that's good but also at the
same time you know justin fields has
only played one year of college football
you know and not to say he can't still
have a great nfl career but the way you
get better at playing football is to
wait for it
play football and that is a hard one
there it really is but i think mike i do
lie in the camp of
if you're if you're looked at as one of
those guys first round second round type
guy and you're in the big ten or pac-12
and they're gonna play spring football
uh i would say for those guys i air
right now and i gotta flush this out in
my brain a little more or flesh it out
sorry uh or both or both right but we'll
have to we'll have to we'll have to call
aunt wendy we're gonna have to clarify
flush works there that's right
we'll we'll get her to clarify but
i would tend not to play if i were that
kind of guy if i was a high ranking you
know first second round pick going into
the year i would just protect my
interest start working out you know
hopefully you can start making yourself
available to teams to do workouts and
things like that and show what you got
from there and just go back to the old
saying like you always said mike hey
look there's plenty of film on me for
the last two years there you see me you
know get over it
look at me and some workouts and
evaluate from there and uh i would tend
to do that if i certainly you know one
of those those high-end prospects
yeah i mean it is a challenge uh and
it's unfortunate if you are one of these
guys
who
would have if he played college football
this fall ascended the way joe burrow
did last year yeah joe burrow
acknowledged that earlier this week but
for the 2019 college football season he
may not have been drafted he said i'd be
looking for a job right now
and what that guy could do this year and
how it could change things for him
it's it's sad it's not going to happen
and then the question becomes and i
think the nfl
now that the big 10 and the pac-12 have
bumped to the spring i think it's
incumbent on the nfl to make it known
yeah asap for the benefit of the kids so
they can make a responsible decision
right are you moving the draft or are
you not moving the draft because if the
nfl decides to be coy about it you'll
just have the kids just hang around well
hey maybe maybe you know because the
coaches will be saying hey you know but
i i think they're going to move the
draft so it's in your best interests and
mine for you to stick around and play
and help us win games and me uh and not
leave to get ready for the draft in
april
because it's not gonna happen in april
trust me on that yeah and if the nfl
just doesn't make an announcement you
can you can you know you can pull that
one off uh so i i hope the nfl fairly
quickly will make it known what it plans
to do now that two of the five major
conferences aren't going to play this
fall
um and and maybe the nfl just waits to
see whether they even play in the spring
right cause that's the thing chris yeah
waiting until the spring isn't some
silver bullet here that's gonna solve
their problem they're just kicking the
can
four months farther down the line and
again
this is not rooting for the outcome this
is applying foresight to the facts as we
currently know them do you feel
confident they're going to be able to
play in the spring based on what's
currently going on chris uh
no i don't i don't necessarily i i don't
not not for college football i still
don't feel that confident about it you
know it's different of course it's
amateur yeah nfl players are taking a
risk they're also collecting some big
checks there and then you know the nfl's
got a lot of money and they got 32 teams
under that umbrella and they're doing it
as well as they can i don't know if i
feel that same way about college
football plus i look at it and go you
know so so what are we going to do i
mean what's going to happen here justin
fields is going to play spring football
play what 14 games
get a month or two off and then what be
the starting quarterback for some team
and play another 16 games he's gonna
he's gonna play 30 games in a year in a
calendar year that's insane you want to
talk about player safety and then the
other aspect mike i'll just hit on real
quick is you know
these teams too the nfl if season goes
as planned right now
you know man bumping the draft back
that's really gonna affect how you you
prepare your football team and free
agency you wouldn't know what your
team's gonna be even until you start
going to training camp because i would
think that that draft you know would
have to end you know end of may or early
june or something like that now if they
were to bump it back so it really causes
some issues for the team building aspect
of an nfl football team and the
balancing of the salary cap and all
those things so there are certainly some
unintended consequences uh
uh there that gotta be you know talked
about a little bit
there's a point you made that i think we
cannot
overstate
whether you're an underclassman
who would be back in 2021 or someone who
is leaving for the nfl you are looking
at a calendar year january through
december that consists
of two football seasons yeah and you're
right chris let's say that 2019 had been
played spring of 2020 joe burrow emerges
the draft happens in june the bengals
make him the first overall pick and they
say hey joe you just played 15 college
games right come on and play and start
16 games for us starting in september
the health and safety aspect i think is
very real the pressure will be
significant on the colleges who welcome
back guys who play in the spring yeah
and on the pro teams who bring the guys
in as rookies and so then you're
basically giving these guys a red shirt
season so
look the sooner that these colleges know
what they're going to do
the sooner the nfl can make a decision
you know meanwhile the nfl's spinning
all these plates over trying to get
their own 2020 season in i mean this
just complicates everything for everyone
we'll see what happens we'll continue to
monitor it every day here at pft live
and also around the clock of
profootballtalk.com
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports